Hi there! We had this question on our AI
Coffee Break Quiz recently, and we must
discuss its answer here, because we never had
such a contested question before on our Quiz.
So, if you do not know what I’m talking
about here, follow Ms. Coffee Bean to
the Community Tab of this channel,
because we have quite the set of
Machine Learning related quiz questions,
and a new question is coming each day!
But let’s get to our question about
the sequence length of the transformer.
It’s not a simple question, not gonna lie.
The answer depends a bit on how one reads it.
Cristian Garcia noted very well
that transformers do not process
just sequences, but something more general:
a sequence without order, which is a set.
The sequential nature of the data becomes
clear to the transformer only because we
add positional embeddings to encode the order
in which the data comes in (if it is the case).
For more about this, check
some of our previous videos.
But supposing we are processing a sequence with
a given model, for example a sequence of words:
Does the sequence always have to have
the same length, or can this length vary?
And it’s a valid question, because there are
architectures, like convolutional architectures
with a fully connected layer in the end where
the input must have always the same size.
If the image is not the right size, it
gets resized during preprocessing. So we
will get to answer this question
for the transformer in two ways:
First by looking into the code, and
then theoretically, because well,
one just does not need to play around a
lot with a transformer from HuggingFace
to notice that inputs which have
different lengths are possible.
So yes, the things we want to
process with a transformer can have
variable lengths. The tokenizer just
gives us more token IDs as output and
an attention mask full of ones, but with
more ones as the sequence grows bigger.
But because of the quadratically scaling
attention in compute, you will also notice
parameters in the transformers library limiting
the sequence length, which has the effect of
truncating everything which exceeds that length
to keep memory and computation in bounds.
Looking at the BERT tokenizer documentation,
we also see the pad token and its explanation.
By padding the sequence to a maximum length,
we can produce inputs of fixed
length for the transformer.
Even the sequence is shorter than the maximum
length, our input length has always the same size,
because the sequence is padded with the PAD token
and the attention mask is padded with zeros.
And all this trouble is for efficiency
reasons in the implementation when we
want to train or do inference on more than
one sample at once. Because in that case,
tensors in a batch should have the same size
such that the GPU can handle this efficiently.
Therefore, the answer to this question
of whether transformers process
sequences of a predefined length or a
variable length is both yes and no. Yes,
sequence length can vary, as in: yes, the
transformer can process any length, but
also no, because efficient implementations
fix the length to a maximum length anyway.
But in principle (and I think this is the
most important thing about transformers):
If everything with positional encodings and
training works well for every sequence length,
there is no reason for why transformers should be
bound to a specific set size (or sequence length).
Because the feed forward layers
we see here are the same,
no matter the position of
the token we are looking at.
So even if we add here one more token at the
end, this does not care as we take the same
feed forward module and its weights
and apply on the newly added tokens.
And the attention is also not caring about the
sequence length as it just computes a pairwise
score given a vector and another vector,
so it just looks at vector pairs at a time.
Therefore, Ms. Coffee Bean would
rather say that transformers process
sequences of variable length – in principle.
Okay, bye!